this man had me at hello when he
strolled onto the campus at the
university of michigan and he's been on
the show many many times and i'm
thrilled to be able to call him a friend
so when a friend has a seminal moment a
milestone moment a capstone career
moment happened to him or her i always
call up and say hey congratulations and
this is going to suffice is that the
great the one and only hall of famer
chris webber back here on the rich eisen
show on the mercedes-benz vans phone
line how are you c webb
hey well doing great i'm doing great
thank you thank you of course what is
going through your mind coursing through
your veins beating in your heart right
now chris webber man it's uh it's it's
crazy uh my wife was in the room and she
just walked out but she i had your own
speaker and he said the hall of fame or
whatever and she looked back and laughed
and clapped and i was just like yes wow
you know
it's still getting still getting settled
with it man still digesting it because
it's uh it's overwhelming well i mean
let's walk through the weekend because i
i imagine it felt like a wedding right
where it goes fast it goes your whole
family's there and it's a big moment for
you and i'm wondering did you like stop
at any moment and be able to take it in
take in the moment chris you know what i
i was so the night after um
this shrine is saturday i i have just a
small little dinner and it was
you know
um just just you know
no extras it's just the people kind of i
grew up with it wasn't like a party
where you had to say hi or people didn't
know each other everybody knew each
other and
i just got you know was able to thank
everybody you know personally that i may
have missed in the speech or or talk a
little bit to them about you know
specific stories with them and what they
meant why they meant so much to me maybe
that i wasn't able to share on stage and
so i really did and it was really
through the people because i i do
remember games and things like that and
you know don't get me wrong with
teammates but you know i i really
remember more of the moments and and
certain things that you know that that
were great during that season or some of
our best memories and so it was really
cool um seeing you know so many uh
family members coaches and things like
that that i had and uh yeah i did get a
chance to kind of enjoy it the thing
that i i always love there's two things
there's two parts about a hall of fame
weekend i've been around almost 20 of
them for the pro football hall of fame
and i want to take it one by one uh with
you the first the first of the two is
the basketball gods
bestowing upon you obviously the great
gift that puts you in the hall of fame
and your your ability to use that to get
you in the hall of fame
uh with a random selection of other
people who had it happen to them
uh
and it's just always interesting to see
the class together and get to know one
one another did you meet anybody or
renew any acquaintances or
you know walk me through you and your
classmates going into springfield
together
bobby dandridge is crazy
funniest he's the funniest man i love
him
and his wife and uh
man he's uh
he's he's just he's awesome man
he's a joke a minute and uh i had a lot
of fun not only watching this speech but
hanging out with charlie scott i got a
chance to hang out with before last year
and i was looking for him i actually got
found his number and uh but he was so
much fun you know too in new york out of
talks a lot of junk but
um
you know bosch uh
you know my my love for bosch grows more
and more um
we you know
didn't i i didn't hang out with players
uh during our time i actually stayed
away from players didn't want to work
out with them wanting to keep them as
enemies it was a different time and
place and a lot of them i'm cooler with
now but with bosch um
you know i i just uh i just love his
kids i respect him and
you know when you really think about the
story again having to retire 31 even
though he had championships and things
like that um you know he just seemed to
be cool but the best moment
prior that i had there with the hall of
fame was with ray allen
um and it was after
um the ceremony
and um
[Music]
we just had a conversation and um
i ran somebody that i really respect a
lot and it was probably one of the best
conversations within the athlete that
i've ever had really
can you share anything from what are you
you know
um whatever you can share from that
after you just said that it was crazy it
was just um
i
i don't
i don't know how man it was just that he
he just said some some words to me that
were encouraging
and
he relayed something that his wife has
said to me just about um
uh
kind of how i grew up my teachers or
something like that but it led to just a
deeper conversation and for somebody
that has principles that he has
and that i really respect it it meant a
lot we never really got to talk and
that's part of it part of it was
you know uh i stayed away from hooper's
i had a wall up and you know
he addressed that and then we kind of
just addressed
you know some really good things and it
was just it was it was cool he got where
i was coming from sorry to be speaking
and
you know cold or anything i'm not trying
to but really it was overwhelming and
i'm trying not even to get back in that
space of remembering the conversation
because uh is that because you know i'm
not trying to be crying on the rich eyes
no no
well then then let me add a little bit
of levity how was uh paul pierce's
shabbat dinner that friday night did you
get one of those in there with him
no i didn't have one dude
i bet it was crazy i bet it was nice why
didn't you i didn't check my instagram
stories friday night i imagine that was
a lit shabbat dinner for uh
hall of fame weekend
webber here on the rich eisen show well
then i i i will proffer to say that
maybe
uh i'll give you a tear a teardrop
warning here because the second
aspect of a hall of fame weekend that i
love watching is family
getting together right and journeys and
i know your dad who you're named after
chris is not your first name
um
that your dad slipped the jacket on you
which is one of my favorite moments i'm
the host of the jacket dinner at the
hall of fame
every year and it's one of my favorite
gigs to to mc um what was that moment
like for you chris webber
it was it was an incredible moment man i
mean
the best part about it is you know i
have a lot of brothers and so
when it's somebody's graduation with
somebody else's moment usually
there's a clown in our family that's you
know stealing all the energy of giving
all the energy just to let the person
enjoy it and
my whole family enjoyed it so much that
i really
enjoyed it was their weekend you know
instead of just tiptoeing around and
they were like no this is our weekend
and so it was just so fun to see
everybody embracing it having my father
do that man
it was um it's
it's the crowded moment you know having
him
be there with me drafted uh knowing what
he went through
growing up and then you know you know
him knowing that that's the reason so
before i got on the plane
uh it before i got on the plane um
i uh
he was at a restaurant and i gave him
the my bag with the ring and
champagne and everything and i'm like
here in the trophy i'm like hey take
this with you
and uh you know he's like no no no i
can't take it i can't take it and then
he started to kind of tear up and i just
ran and i was like damn i left the
champagne
in there because he doesn't drink and
i'm like i need that champagne
it's one of the best moments man uh it
was one of the best moments ever man i
can't lie to you and and the speech i
was so nervous i forgot to say that it
was their 50th wedding anniversary when
i was here celebrating it with them and
all this but hey he got the point but it
was my honor man it was it was my honor
to have him put that jacket on me so are
you saying chris webber
you got into the basketball hall of fame
in springfield massachusetts on the same
weekend or even day
of your parents 50th wedding anniversary
is that a true story is that it no the
wedding anniversary was uh july 31st but
it was the same you know year i was
saying yeah
anniversary that is
believable that is so cool that is so
cool so um let me ask you this chris
webber if i had some time some ability
to wave a wand because i saw juwan was
there and that steve fisher was there if
i had somehow intruded
into a moment with you and the rest of
the fab five and said one day you were
gonna be
wearing a jacket for the hall of fame
and you'd be the first one there what
would you have said chris wilbur
on that day
oh man i would have i mean
uh
i
uh i wouldn't believe that i would have
been the whole thing
so we got to we had to discuss that
first but um
seeing fish there and juan and talking
to ray
um on texting all that is it's awesome
man and it is you know we we are we're
family and you know i think you're gonna
see everybody very soon and uh actually
i'm going to practice pretty soon so
um i just can't wait you know i
as i said you know
it you know i love the university of
michigan hopefully all the fans
understand especially from michigan and
sacramento that
you know that me being there gives means
you're in and we're all in together so i
can't wait to go
celebrate hang on going home coming
hanging out at the games and things like
that so um yeah i'm i'm sure i'm i'm
very sure um and i'm sure juwan's gonna
be there forever so we're gonna have a
lot of time to celebrate get back but
yeah man uh
we're back and hopefully you know um
every fan knows that hopefully everybody
michigan knows that and uh i'm glad a
lot of the young high school kids know
that because uh man i got a lot of dm
saying congratulations congratulations
from some for some great you know kids
out there so um yeah man i love uh
michigan and glad that hopefully uh you
know hopefully you can just go forward
and enjoy some winning days with the
football basketball and all sports there
michigan yeah so you know c webb you'd
mentioned earlier that you were walled
up around other players when you're in
the nba and
now you're saying that the walls are are
coming down and i'm just wondering if
all the walls for you with everything
that's gone on over the last 25 years
somehow are coming down or
disintegrating or beginning to come down
because you got this jacket man i mean
you're in this is it you were there's
you proved it you did it fact doesn't
matter what happened back in the early
90s what you did is done and never gonna
be taken away from you that's that's
forever more your kids and their kids
and their kids will go to springfield
and see you i'm i'm wondering how that's
landing on you right now
chris yeah no i think i think is i think
it's it is awesome you know that this
will happen
but
having to deal with
you know uh not being in or
or other things you know you i believe
in working on yourself all the time and
hopefully
the resolve over the past you know 10 15
years is what got me to this point
and you know because it's an award
they just say okay this is cool this is
cool i i kind of would be like damn damn
where's the process you know that kind
of means that an war makes you you know
do that and so you know i haven't
explained a lot of things and talked
about a lot of things but i wouldn't
um i wouldn't say a wall is coming down
i would just say it's just
more opportunity for someone to get to
to know me and that's kind of what me
and ray were talking about because he's
kind of been
judged the same way as well or or other
things like that and so
no i think it's just um
life's process and you know whether it's
having
twins whether it's um living life
whether it's just
trying to be a better person um
you know you're gonna have to you know
work on making decisions out of love not
fear work on forgiveness
um you know gratitude humility and so um
those are things i had like a
relationship between me and god so
hopefully
you know if i serve that purpose
everything with man is you know
secondary because that's the way it
should live so hopefully you know just
every day you get better and enjoy
um but i'm gonna be around basketball
and i'm very competitive and so
you know if you see me as an owner of a
team don't expect me to hang out with 29
other owners because i wouldn't change
anything about my work ethic or style
the way that i play but um i definitely
want to become a better person every day
respects the goal well uh
it seems that then it would be counter
of me to say what i'm about to say after
you were so inspiring i don't want to
talk to james dolan either so i totally
hear you brother
so that's is that is that the plan for
you is ownership that's what you're
you're that's in the on the radar the
sea web radar right now as you know i
think magic and junior bridgeman and
other guys um you know um i haven't
really talked about a lot of going on
the business side but i'm very excited
what's been accomplished okay and um
and and what's happening in the future
you know i definitely want to be around
basketball forever i mean it's no secret
um my team was in for the
bid of the atlanta hawks a few years
back and so you know yeah i would love
that to be the goal
that is a goal love still trying to win
the championship but in the meantime you
know there's a lot of work and to be
done and some you know some awesome
opportunities
um but yeah i'm excited on the business
side for what junior brisbane magic
isaiah vinnie johnson and so many others
that are excelling in business beyond
what people may know wayne wayne and
then you know kind of showing me the way
dwyane wade too right there he is you're
seeing dwyane wade sitting courtside
with the with the jobs yeah yeah i mean
oh yeah dwyane wade's the awesome owner
oh yeah i'm not talking about the owners
of ownership though i mean you know
junior bridgeman what he's done as far
as in business um
yeah all right john's sending those guys
so i mean more on the other side what
magic has done but yeah i mean the way
man anything dwyane wade touches his
goal especially with his clothing and
everything else so as far as
entrepreneurs yeah he's a guy that
you know definitely uh is rocking and
doing this thing and i admire as well
yeah you'll be at future events too in
the same jacket that's for sure one day
oh man i know yeah between coming your
way
all right um so last one for you uh you
you keep hinting at it i'm just gonna
walk straight through the front door so
you're gonna see we're gonna see a a fab
five uh reunion photo coming up so you
did you sure i'm sure you will oh i'm
sure i mean why not
all right
why not i mean i want it on i love the
i'm sure it'll happen so i don't even
think that's like a surprise anymore or
like uh
you know
it is newsworthy i can't wait till it
happens but yeah i think that's just um
you know it's just a matter of time
again juwan's the head coach yeah and
then winning and uh having a successful
program is most important but uh yeah
we're definitely gonna be there support
them so i can't wait okay yeah i'll be
there i'll i'll hop in and take the
selfie i want in
you know everybody everybody thinks
please everybody thinks palink is the
other the the the the sixth man and no
no no i'm here in l.a y'all know you
were there
baby that you were you the man with the
pen in your hand doing your thing back
there i'll be there i'll be there no i
would have just graduated you you you
kept you and desmond kept bridging me
back to the school after i graduated you
and desmond oh man that's what you you
know what a time i'll tell you what if
it if if it when i find out when it
happens or whatever because it'll be
such a special moment i'll text you man
i'll text you okay and let you know you
better hurry up and jump on that plane
all right before i let you go back to
fatherhood i will give you the floor as
always uh the lions came close i don't
know if you missed it because you were
flying back from massachusetts or
anything like that but you see what
happened with the lines in the first
week these lines came very close
um
you know i'm gonna leave it i believe
that i love our lines uh my brother let
me tell you this very sam is a great man
my brother sent me a
video from barry sanders you know uh
congratulate me great that was the
highlight of my son sunday imagine
getting that you know while i'm filling
out making checking on my fantasy roster
but
i do want to talk about this okay
because i want to say i know experts you
know i and since i argue with fans they
can argue with me yes but rich i want to
put on record i'm not one of these
fairweather guys i said when the trade
happened
that the rams were going to be my team
i said it yep i cried in my t.o voice
about my quarterback saying that's my
quarterback
yeah i saw what he did he did the man
only had two i think 2 000 yard rushers
in his whole career why wouldn't he play
well why couldn't he throw off the pass
action you know that boy from georgia
where they come on man i'm trying to
tell you i'm trying to tell you but
that's okay me and vegas already have an
agreement or we already gonna see what's
gonna happen but watch out for my rams
staffer man he looked phenomenal he was
great he was terrific i know oh this is
going to be great in the back oh my god
domino up front i'm trying to tell you
everybody oh stafford he was with the
losing team he was with this as an
athlete i just want to say it's all
about opportunity remember chauncey
phillips remember they said he's a
malcontent couldn't play got traded from
the celtics and see what happened years
later don't get me wrong a lot of it is
the player's fault i'm not saying that
but a lot of it is
opportunity and situation so i'm just
happy to see him you know
see him get a real shot at it while he
still has the arm and boy does he have
on
love you chris weber congratulations
you're a hall of famer man um and to
your whole family this was uh great to
see this weekend and i appreciate you
coming on the show to let me tell the
whole world how i feel about you and
[Music]
i
congratulations
it uh appreciate that
i know
yeah when we all get together for that
let's do it thanks again chris and go
enjoy the rest of your day and your
family and we'll chat soon congrats
chris that's c-webb everybody there you
go
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here